hey I'm Eddie Wu and here are my top
three tips for studying well and doing
your best in your final exams tip number
one study by explaining everyone knows
that in a subject like mathematics it's
really important to do practice to
attempt as many questions as you can and
be really comfortable and familiar with
the kinds of things you're going to need
to solve when you get into your final
assessment tasks however what I would
encourage in addition to just doing
questions and getting the answers is to
actually explain the questions and
answers that you're doing I think it's
far more valuable to attempt a smaller
number of questions but then spend the
time with a peer or a family member to
say okay I'm going to sit down with this
question and I'm going to tell you why
the working is what it is and I'm going
to also articulate and justify why the
answer is one that makes sense actually
going through the work of explaining
forces you to understand something more
deeply in fact it was the physicist
Richard Feynman who said you do not
understand something truly until you can
explain it simply I reckon 95 of the
reason why I am any good at mathematics
is because I spent so many years
teaching it and oftentimes I would think
I understood something until I put
myself in the position of having to
communicate it to someone else and
that's when it revealed to me that
actually there's deeper understanding
that I didn't yet have so when you're
studying don't just do questions
actually take some of those answers that
you come up with and explain them to
other people tip number two work on your
little Errors By building your
conceptual memory one of the things that
plagues every mathematics students is
what we often call Silly mistakes these
are the kinds of things where you do the
exam you complete it you finish off and
when you get the marks back you look and
you think how did I get this wrong I
know how this question works I had the
right formula I just did something silly
like two times three equals five instead
of six these silly mistakes can be
really frustrating because there are
places where we lose marks where we knew
we we could have gotten them and we feel
very silly afterwards now I used to call
these careless errors these silly
mistakes seemed like we just weren't
paying attention when we were doing it
but the longer I teach the more I
realize that even though sometimes it is
that I was being careless in my working
there are other reasons underneath why
these little errors creep into our work
and the biggest one that I come up with
most frequently is what I call
conceptual memory when you learn a
concept for the first time in a subject
like mathematics it'll have many
different sub components and it takes up
all of your effort and working memory to
learn what those things are just as an
example the quadratic formula now I can
say that to you really quickly even
though when I first learned it it was a
lot of different ideas all together
think about it x equals minus B plus or
minus the square root of B squared minus
4 AC divided by 2 a there you go that's
16 separate little things that when I
first learned them absolutely took all
of my attention and effort to learn but
now I can say the quadratic formula and
more importantly I can use it without
even sparing a second thought how did
that happen it's because I've taken time
many many hours to build my memory of
that concept so that now it's no longer
16 different ideas in my mind it's just
one now what does this have to do with
little errors well you can imagine if
you are using a formula or an algorithm
or a problem-solving technique in a
question and you're not yet familiar
with it that you don't have that
conceptual memory that I'm talking about
that when you realize in the question
that you have to use this all of your
attention will go to say the quadratic
formula and it's really easy for your
mind to lose track of other pieces of
information in the question that are
relevant to solving the question and so
what happens is your mind can't keep
track of everything and before you know
it you've made an error without even
realizing it because the things you
needed to focus on just didn't have
enough space in your working memory so
if you really want to minimize the
number of little errors that happen some
of them are unavoidable and you can only
fix them up by going back and checking
on your work but others of them can
really be minimized if you work on
building your conceptual memory my final
tip number three is to space out your
learning now a less poetic way of saying
that is just to say don't cram when
you're studying and revising except we
all kind of know in the back of our
minds that cramming is not a very good
idea and yet we do it anyway so how can
I convince you to be a little more
disciplined in having a regular study
program rather than leaving everything
to the last minute and cramming just a
few hours days weeks before the exam
studies show that spacing out our
learning something called distributed
practice is really important for
embedding the ideas and the skills that
we're learning and if you have a think
about it you'll understand why something
that we cram in at the last minute but
then forget about after the exam is
finished kind of signals to our brain
that this is just important for a short
amount of time and it doesn't really
matter so surprise surprise your brain
doesn't actually deeply put effort into
actually retaining those memories long
term however if you think about about
anything that you have done regularly
and steadily that signals to your brain
hey this is important I do this over and
over again it must really matter because
it's a regular part of your routine and
so what this does is it enforces the
neural Pathways in your mind and it
really sinks in those things that you're
trying to remember and become good at so
space out your learning over time have a
schedule make sure you set it you know
every week or Fortnight you're going to
be revising exams and not just right at
the very end and this is one of the ways
that you'll ensure your long-term memory
really sticks for the things that you've
learned during class so in summary the
most effective way to learn a lot of
things is by forcing yourself to explain
it to others around you minimize the
little areas that you have by deepening
your conceptual understanding and that
comes from deliberate practice and
lastly space out your learning and
revision and stick to a schedule the
best time to begin was probably two
weeks ago but the next best time after
that is right now so all the best in
your studies and all your assessment
tasks